welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston this is a breakdown of Star Wars
Ahsoka episode 8 the finale the Jedi the
witch and the warlord a title that
totally seems inspired by C.S Lewis's
The Lion The Witch the Wardrobe and I'm
choosing to believe that balance goal is
our Aslan because Ray Stevenson was my
hero this season and he's right where he
should be on the hand of the father from
the argonathy gods of mortis Clone Wars
knight sister callbacks and other great
Star Wars Easter eggs let's break down
this episode scene by scene for the
details you missed and you know what a
huge thanks to all of you for joining us
this season of Ahsoka it has really been
my honor to share my Tuesdays and
Wednesdays with you all and if anything
in these videos has inspired you to
watch stories a little bit more deeply
or just as made you feel seen as a nerd
who looks too far into things me staying
up until 2 39 a.m writing these analysis
has been well worth the effort so thanks
again and let's dive into the episode
okay we opened with Kevin kiner's
ceremonial drum beat
yeah kudos to the word kainer has been
doing all this season these drums in the
hint of bass and organ pair perfectly
with this opening shot of thrawn's
chimera placed on the peridia Fortress
as the gothic church organ of thrawn's
majesty pairs with the Grassroots dark
magic of the night sisters really this
opening shot is just perfectly bisected
by a center dividing line formed by The
Fortress and the fold of the Chimera its
underbelly patterned as it was in Rebels
thrawn orders Enoch to dispatch two type
fighters to the Jedi location wanting to
cover his bases I've watched many an
imperial officer and make the same
assumptions about the Rebellion yeah
he's suddenly referring to officers like
Governor price from Rebels who made a
number of mistakes underestimating the
small number of Jedi including when she
bombed a fuel Depot that killed Kanan
Jairus but allowed Ezra and Sabine and
Hera to escape but thrawn also admits
even I feel Victor
heroics of a single Jedi never again
he's likely referring to Ezra Bridger
whom thrawn allowed to board the Chimera
in the rebels final episodes just to
face defeat when Ezra summoned the
pergol but I also like to think thrawn
might be referring to his time with
Anakin Skywalker documented in Timothy
zahn's 2018 thrawn Alliance a really
great read that's a dual timeline story
about thrawn partnering with Darth Vader
on a mission to Batu during the
galactics of war and yes Batu that is a
location in Disney's Galaxy's Edge but
this story also flashes back to a clone
wars era Mission between thrawn and
Anakin Skywalker so yeah this is a round
when thrawn begins to surmise that
certain qualities about Vader totally
remind him of that strapping young Jedi
he went on that mission with and it is
why I think when he learned that Ahsoka
Tana's master was Anakin he went oh
I just like the idea that thrawn left
that forever haunted that despite his
brilliant military mind he remains
befuddled by Jedi in their weird culty
ways speaking of weird culty ways the
three great mothers thank Morgan L Smith
she who heard our dreams across the
Stars
come forward interesting that they say
our dreams as in they actually
subconsciously called to Morgan while
they were sleeping I have a theory about
that that I'll get to later they tell
Morgan you shall be rewarded
the gift
of Shadows
yeah I hear that spooky Echo following
it off Shadows sounding like the voice
of night sister Spirits already being
invoked for this ritual they chant do
you pledge yourself
to The Sisterhood
to the magics
to the old ways
do you abandon your old life
four there's a new one your loyalty
your life yes this is the same exact
night sister baptismal Creed that mother
talzin spoke to asajj Ventress in Clone
Wars season 4 episode 19 Massacre do you
pledge yourself to The Sisterhood to the
Magics and the old ways do you abandon
your old life or this new one
your loyalty
your life Assange Ventress was the death
Marian female four Caesar mentioned by
Anakin's recording last episode she's
actually the one who gave him that scar
this night sister baptism happens in the
episode when Dooku and Grievous come to
death mirror to wipe out most of the
night's sister coven and the part of the
Creed do you abandon your old life for
this new one is spoken by actropaw who
is based on the Greek fate who cuts the
threat of life so she's asking Morgan
and God can we just like acknowledge
that her name is Morgan it sounds like a
name some drunk girl yells across a
party Marianne I thought you were gonna
day day anyway I'm sorry about that
actionpa is asking Morgan to end her old
life so a new one can begin and then
your loyalty your life is spoken by
lekisis the Fate who measures the thread
as Morgan's loyalty to the Knight
sisters is something expected to run the
duration of her life which unfortunately
we'll see this episode ain't that long
whereas mother's house and levitated to
Sanchez's body with Green Knights is her
sorcery it looked awesome they ain't got
the budget for wire work here so instead
they just kind of like burn Morgan's
face like Harry Potter on Professor
squirrel's face scalding some green fire
to make Morgan's facial markings more
pronounced similar to theirs but really
the coolest thing about this is the
sound design when clotho first steps up
to Morgan we hear voices and Whispers of
past night sisters working their way
into clotho's hands
[Music]
and then as clotho forces the fire into
her face we actually hear these guttural
moons
[Music]
maybe it's because I just watched 1990s
ghost but this reminds me of the sounds
of the Shadow Demons that drag evil
souls to Hell which they actually
created by pitching down and stretching
out the sounds of babies crying
[Applause]
[Music]
they conjure this sword
the blade
oh Towson the blade of thousand is the
weapon carried by mother Towson when she
dueled Mace Windu in Clone Wars season 6
episode 9 that disappeared part two
talzin conducts the ritual on the moons
our Dosa sticks to extract the living
force from Queen Julia Julia you
Towson was hoping to become more
powerful than any Jedi or Sith jar jar
helps in this episode the Tarzan ends up
dissipating in some green mist and she
would actually later go on to die while
trying to save her son Maul from capture
in the son of death mirror comic but
this health of the blade of talson has a
pale white color and a black pommel
which do match the color tones of
towson's face and the other great mother
faces perhaps her entire spiritual
Essence lives on inside this weapon but
why do they reward Morgan with the sword
perhaps these Fates foresee Morgan
having to die A Warrior's death and
sacrifice herself so the rest of them
can escape this blessing is a curse in
Disguise that might be why it's called
the gift of shadow and isn't it
in between Morgan and Sabine and Ahsoka
The Rescuers of the people who are
stringed on this planet are the ones who
have to trade places with them we hear
the classic Star Wars Claxton alarm
blaring
foreign
Fighters flank thrawn as they depart
yeah I am ready to see this guy as a
villain of a Star Wars movie so the
Titleist episode the Jedi the witch and
the warlord must absolutely be a NADA CS
Lewis is The Lion The Witch in the
wardrobe or The Chronicles of Narnia
series The Warlord probably referring to
thrawn the witch probably Morgan and the
Jedi would be well it could be a few
people Ahsoka Sabine Ezra Anakin
remember Jedi is also plural so it could
be all of them Dave filoni did say that
when he first conceived of the world
Between Worlds he got that name from the
wood between the worlds in The Lion the
Witch and the Wardrobe Ezra builds a new
lightsaber hilt oh no that's not gonna
work look I'm going to work what are you
talking about blade emitters too narrow
too narrow this seems like a meta
response to the rebels viewers who
complain that the lightsabers on the
series were too narrow this would
technically be the third lightsaber Ezra
constructed for himself after his
original one with the blue blade and
then the new one with the green blade
and later seasons of rebels that Sabine
now carries but where would Ezra have
gotten the kyber crystal for this blade
who yeah I must keep a drawer of kyber
crystals handy I just think it's a bit
odd because huyang of anybody would know
that the Jedi pairing with their kyber
crystals is a sacred process that
determines how well the lightsaber
channels their connection to the force
but you know whatever speed and Ezra
tell huyang that Kane and Jairus taught
Ezra how to build a lightsaber and who
Yang remembers Kanan I told you I taught
almost every youngling at the Jedi
Temple including your master the other
boy Caleb was very curious a little shy
perhaps yes he calls him Caleb as before
he used the Alias of Canon Juris during
the Rebellion era he went by Caleb Doom
huyang also says of Caleb's shyness
yeah this is great because it
acknowledges how weird it must have been
to be a young lean during the Clone Wars
which I really appreciated this season
of Ahsoka episode 5 exploring how messed
up it is that the Jedi deployed child
soldiers and remember the season
premiere of bad batch shows the
heartbreaking moment Caleb Doom lost his
master debit balaba and now the member
of the bad batch Hunter allowed Caleb to
escape shape after Caleb did an insane
morphe style for Sleep across the
waterfall that Ezra nearly recreates
this episode hu Yang presents Ezra with
a specific blade emitter with his disc
around it matching the one that Kane and
Jairus AKA Caleb had the end of his Hilt
who Yang says I had two of those Kanan
took the one the other eye held on to in
case he ever needed it now Ezra's blade
is blue once again like his very first
saber bringing him full circle with the
very first kyber Crystal that he got
during this moment with Yoda in the
lothal Jedi Temple that was technically
the world Between Worlds early on and
Rebels huyang reveals that Ahsoka became
concerned that Sabine was training to be
a Jedi for the wrong reasons at the end
of the war the Empire purged the entire
surface of the planet
killing hundreds of thousands her family
we're all lost exactly yes he's
referring to the Knight of a thousand
Tears first mentioned in the Mandalorian
season one finale and then shown in the
book of Boba Fett chapter five when Moth
Gideon's forces dropped Fusion bombs on
the planet and we learned that this
happened at the end of the Galactic
Civil War so sometime around the Battle
of Endor maybe before the final final
battle of that war the Battle of jakku
that mock Gideon pulled a real shitty
late Sucker Punch on Mandalore and Esra
asks about sabine's family because yeah
he spent a lot of time with the Wren
family in the first couple episodes of
rebels season four he knew them hu Yang
says that Ahsoka feared that Sabine
would reach her full potential become
dangerous which sounds like Ahsoka
recognizes how Anakin losing his mother
shmee is really what started his path to
the dark side so it wasn't really
sabine's failure it was ahsoka's fear
that caused that student teacher
relationship to fall apart Sabina nasoka
though finally discussed sabine's
decision to give Balin the map sphere
and Sabine says sorry
yes we know from Han and leian Empire I
know it's Star Wars for I love you
Ahsoka says over the years I've made my
share of difficult choices often no one
understood my reasons except my master
he always
stood by me yes we're reminded of the
time when Ahsoka left the Jedi Order at
the end of Clone Wars season 5. I
believed in you I stood by you I know
you believe in me Anakin and I'm
grateful for that I understand wanting
to walk away from the order
I know a line that many over the years
interpreted as Ahsoka possibly hinting
that she knew about Anakin and Padme but
also I know it's Star Wars for I love
you Ahsoka asks have you kept up with
your training I I try I do
I do yes of course the nod to Yoda is
famous do or do not there is no try
inside thrawn's Tie fighters we hear the
signar targeting system beeping from the
original trilogy
now while these ties are aiming for the
T6 from the wide overhead shot you can
see that they first hit the no-t
trailers beneath it so much for the T6
hovering over them as cover Sabine runs
into the cockpit of the T6 and staying
late for no reason she solder checks who
Yang that's probably Natasha Lee Edwards
Izzo being told that they would do a
camera Shake in response to that blast
reigning Sparks or the cockpit but the
special effect I guess comes too late or
maybe the shoulder check comes too early
but either way I like to think she's
just mad at who yank we're talking all
that about her Jedi skills all
season I mean look at who Yang's face
when she bumps him he totally clocks it
Ezra and Ahsoka use the force to prop up
the T6 s bean rigs up a little boost
from the engine and it kind of looks
like Ahsoka gives it an extra Force push
to slingshot it kind of like that extra
push Sabine will give Ezra later now I
cannot explain why this TIE fighter
pilot screams and covers his head
instead of you know quickly veering the
Tie Fighter out of the way or why the
t6's wings aren't totally obliterated
when totally obliterating the Tie
fighters but you know the T6 is
temporarily out of commission and
actually it may the same engine shutdown
sound effect from the Luca Mario library
that they use for the Falcon when it got
tractor beamed into the Death Star in A
New Hope
when Enoch reports to thrawn about the
typewriters it's interesting that thrawn
says to consider all the Tie fighters
lost and to Mark the captain for a
citation this gives us a sense of the
discipline with which thrawn commands
his forces but then interestingly Morgan
gives him parting words to the night
Trooper volunteers the blessing of the
great mothers shall protect you in
battle against the Jedi yeah this
blessing we see later is actually going
to be a resurrection curse and thrawn
confirms those are the volunteers they
were made aware yeah think about it
thrawn could have just ordered Troopers
to go into battle but these ones were
offered the option to partake in this
experiment to keep the Jedi on the
planet for as long as possible even if
that meant death and zombie Resurrection
perhaps part of the night sister spell
is that those who get reanimated have to
first consent to it happening prior to
their deaths Ezra says thrawn found this
place he woke up the witches rebuilt to
Starship
it wasn't safe to come here alone
interesting to learn that the witches
were in some kind of hibernation State
when thrawn arrived and he woke them up
I assume it was a sorcery base because
thrawn's not a sorcerer would have just
had been like beep beep beep beep hey
wake up perhaps the caskets we thought
we were seeing are actually a type of
cryo chamber that anyone could just be
awoken from and that all of these death
Amiri are just sleeping in suspended
animation like if baleen and Shannon
episode 6 were right and the witches
were fleeing paridia from that
mysterious entity that's calling to
Balin it would seem based on this
episode that that entity was the Marxist
Gods so there is some history there that
right now we can only guess at but
perhaps there was some conflict between
the night sisters and the mortise gods
and that most of the night sisters got
the hell off the planet moved to another
galaxy onto the planet dathomir but some
stayed behind in a kind of suspended
animation in case those fleeing night
sisters ever came back to paridia now of
course they didn't Morgan was the first
one to do that and thrawn found them
first and woke up their three leaders
who then called their last living
descendant Morgan elsbeth that could be
why they told Morgan you heard our
dreams because they were sleeping and
astrally projecting to her so again it
might not be caskets transporting but
rather cryopods suspended in I guess
maybe a less severe form of Carbonite
Ezra says he was afraid to come here
alone and Ahsoka responds oh you're not
alone anymore this comes back later in
the big moment with Sabine and you will
die here
alone
not alone
in both cases one cannot help but think
of Gandalf providing backup at the
Battle of Helms Deep into towers and our
man Carl Urban Amber came in with the
line heard from Heaven King stands alone
thrawn commands to bombard them with
turbo lasers into three evade the blasts
breaking ankles reminding me of Kanan
dodging thrawn's bombardment of Chopper
base on atalan and the rebel season 3
finale so Ahsoka Ezra it's a bean
combined their force abilities to open
the gate of the Fortress and there are
more Sith erkata letters around the
frame of the gate actually Zen Keepers
on Twitter was wonderful to begin
translating this for us finding the word
rain and from there I try to translate
the rest of it I think the next two
words are last for all so rain lasts for
all yeah I'm pretty sure this is part of
the passage that Tommy J Wall translated
a couple weeks back raised or praised
gujet's ruler of all Maya's Reign lasts
for all time kujits being the evil ruler
of the ancient zepho race from Jedi fall
in order but is the word praise kujet or
since we don't actually see the p is it
Rey's kujet because they are headed to
dathomir Home of kujit's Tomb and maybe
the night sisters plan to resurrect the
ancient zeppo Force wielding Sage of
kujit the night Troopers fire upon us
Bean Sabine actually manages to deflect
a few shots with her saber and I feel
bad for this guy one of the night
Troopers totally trips on the steps
despite nothing hitting him you know
actors struggling to move around in
stormtrooper armor and helmets is kind
of a long Star Wars tradition dating
back to the guy in the 1977 Star Wars
who bumped his head on the door on the
Death Star
and thank you to betterhelp for
sponsoring this video October is a
stressful time of year school has
started the holidays are approaching
there's less Sun if you are struggling
with something don't force yourself to
Bear it alone get help from a licensed
therapist with better help starting
therapy can be hard the right therapist
for you may not be in your area and some
people struggle with the face-to-face
interaction of therapy with better help
you can have your therapy sessions as a
phone call as a video chat or even via
messaging if you prefer that whatever is
the most comfortable version of therapy
for you just click the link in the
description and answer a few questions
about what you're looking for from
therapy and what your preferences are
better help will then match you with a
therapist from their Network that's
right for you and if you don't really
fit with that therapist which is a
common thing with therapy you can easily
switch to a therapist for no additional
cost without stressing about insurance
or who's in your network or anything
like that mental health is quite the
journey but it isn't important one so
start your journey towards better mental
health click the link in the description
or visit betterhelp.com New rockstars to
help support this Channel and get you 10
off your first month with better help
but sensing that Sabine isn't really
feeling her lightsaber Ahsoka tells her
to switch to her blasters finally
drawing out all the night Troopers so
that you know she can just take turns
shooting them Ezra Force pushes one and
then he slides down it looks like he
slashes one in the butt then Ezra Force
pulls the last two into Ahsoka sabers
sounds like one of those night Troopers
was female and Ahsoka definitely seems
to be enjoying this kill way too much
meanwhile the great mothers chant some
weird words
these are the same exact words of the
chant of Resurrection performed by old
DACA in that Clone Wars Massacre episode
and they're doing the same thing here
resurrecting the night Troopers as
zombies and Kevin kainer samples this
particular music take a listen
yes
aha this is Camille salsouls 1874 dance
Macabre a famous musical riff that comes
up a lot in what we do in the shadows I
love that show but I remember it for my
favorite episode of Buffy the Vampire
Slayer hush
[Music]
by the way this is one of the best gags
of the show where Buffy has to Panama
I'm stabbing with a stake to kill the
gentleman but it looks like something
else and I feel like simply the song
gear might even be an intentional bumpy
reference because Sarah Michelle Geller
who is the wife of Kanan voice actor
Brady Prince Jr and kind of a member of
the Star Wars family because she voiced
the seventh sister in Rebels but the
historical idea of the dance Macabre is
that death appears at midnight every
year on Halloween calling forth the dead
from their graves to dance for him while
he plays the fiddle so that's why this
song begins with the solo violin playing
the tritone which was known in the
medieval times as the diabolus in Musica
or the devil in music so yeah it is
October folks happy Halloween Ahsoka is
ending with this classic spooky needle
drop as witches resurrect zombies I love
it so green light beams from the night
sisters eyes and glows from under the
Stormtroopers helmets Ahsoka asks Ezra
if this has happened before and he oddly
says no this is new which is weird
because in that Rebel season 3 episode
visions and voices Ezra and Sabine do
fight some green night sister spirits
and malls Abode on dothamir spirits that
possess Sabine and Kanan so it's kind of
something he's seen before but I guess
he hasn't seen like dead bodies reanime
but again my favorite part of all this
is how it sounds
that growl is so intense it actually
causes the helmet speaker to peek and
distort like even the tech in this
helmet doesn't know how to filter this
inhuman screen Ezra gets grabbed on the
staircase and Sabine can't get a clean
shot with her blasters to see them so
she has to use her lightsaber and she
gets a clean kill and then from here she
smoothly deflects three more shots it
kind of seems like Ezra being in danger
is what brings the force out of her the
most that actually gives a double
meaning to this line what's your excuse
I missed you he's not just joking like I
missed this kind of banter I miss us
he's literally saying the reason I
didn't keep up with my training is that
I had no one to use the Force 4 until
now so that Chimera docks with the eye
of Scion and yeah it does look a lot
like the Jedi starfighters with their
hyperspace rings and the prequels but
just on a much bigger scale thrawn tells
Morgan at this rate they make it on
board the ship which would be
problematic
we require a little more time this is
such a cool acting Choice by Lawrence
Mickelson like he begins to say
something and then he just decides in
the moment to stay silent and let Morgan
build a subtext that subtext being I
need you to volunteer to stay behind and
hold back those Jedi thrawn says goodbye
with for the Empire yet as he walks off
Morgan Whispers
yeah it sounds like these witches are
ultimately not forever loyal to thrawn
and are really just using them to pursue
their own goals so thrawn's defeat by
many arms surrounding him in a cold
Embrace may occur on dathomir someday
Ahsoka and the others run into Morgan
and I like how Ahsoka instinctively puts
her hand back to stop Sabine from
rushing in and I love the sound that the
blade of Towson makes when it gets
ignited
yeah I heard a force push and then kind
of a
vibration that slows down and then at
the end these little flute bursts
yeah their fight is mostly fun to watch
is really just to listen to this
dialogue between Kevin kiner's
instruments it's like all the animals
and Peter and the Wolf getting in a
melee and I was curious why if Morgan's
whole mission was to stop the Jedi from
getting on the Chimera why she would
just let Ezra and Sabine go right past
her but it's really because Ezra ends
being run into what looked like a couple
of really tall Winklevoss sized Purge
Troopers who have also been zombified as
when Sabine blasts away chunks of this
helmet there's definitely startling
corpse mouth underneath but Sabine
summons a lightsaber with the force and
kills that trooper with a clean head
stab kind of like kylo Ren's been she
moved against the praetorian guard in
The Last Jedi Sabine helps Ezra pay no
mind to the Gap from that Fortress to
the departing Chimera giving him that
extra little Force push it's crazy we do
hear the force theme it's really fun
actually Kanan I remember used a similar
move in the rebels ghost of Geonosis
episode but that was a much smaller Gap
meanwhile Morgan's blade of thousand
severs one of ahsoka's hilts whoa this
is one she said for a while it's a big
deal to lose it and we get to see just
some amazing stunt work by Diana Lee
Santo a long time stunt performer and
god-daughter to Bruce Lee she is so much
fun to watch and I'm gonna miss seeing
her in Star Wars and as Sabine returns
Morgan is pissed she screams cow yeah
and really that's just her anger because
her master thrawn left her alone to die
so she feels pissed that ahsoka's Mentor
student relationship wasn't severed the
same way hers was so it rattles Morgan
and that allows Ahsoka to get the upper
hand she goes on the offensive so being
meanwhile clears those night Troopers
with her lightsaber and her Blaster
together in tandem fully incorporating
Jedi elements with Mandalorian ones
Ahsoka finishes a duel she drives
Morgan's blade into the ground snatching
it from her and a double swipes her with
the lightsaber and the Towson blade and
listen to the sound emitted when Morgan
dies
yeah it's a ghostly whale as she falls
through her knees and rolls over this is
what the great mother sense to know that
Morgan died like a million night sister
Spirit screaming out in Terror suddenly
silenced Ezra gets to do one of his
favorite things from Rebels using a
stormtrooper calm link to impersonate a
stormtrooper and then disguise himself
with stormtrooper armor of course he
does this thrawn orders to bombard The
Fortress and clotho gives him a look she
doesn't stop him from destroying their
ancestral home but it is another little
example of these night sisters harboring
a different agenda and possibly turning
on thrawn one day Ahsoka and Sabine
escape the night Troopers by jumping off
the ledge seemingly to their death but
nope like Marty McFly on the flying
DeLorean and Back to the Future Part Two
they surf the T6 and Escape as a
fortress collapses thrawn at chats with
Ahsoka saying I know you
because I knew your master
one wonders
just how similar you might become yeah
to me this is confirmation that thrawn
totally knew that Anakin became Vader
and then he says perhaps this is
where a ronin such a shoe belongs Ronin
Ronan we're masterless Samurai in feudal
Japan and of course since the Jedi have
their roots in Samurai culture just
makes sense for the term to be used here
for Ahsoka so I guess we need to add
Rune into this shirt Warrior Outcast
Rebel Jedi in a ronin you can get this
shirt by the way at nerd riot.shop like
moth Gideon has said many times before
with Ron leaves with long live the
Empire The Eye of Scion blasts off with
a chimera and you can see thrawn is Just
So Satisfied to be leaping off to
hyperspace by his own choice for a
change Ahsoka and Sabine return to the
no T and Ahsoka sees her bird Mori this
is the representation of the mortis God
the daughter that continues to accompany
Ahsoka throughout her life like it
appeared in the world Between Worlds and
Rebels Vader saw it in the final shot of
the Clone Wars series while he was
searching for Ahsoka the bird even
showed up on a burnt Tree on corvus in
the Mandalorian when we first saw
ahsokan live action so seeing more eye
here tells Ahsoka that she is where she
needs to be they saved Ezra basically
traded places with him but I think there
is something more on peridia or Soca so
onto the epilogue sequence shinhati
joins up with the bandits of pridia and
then Balin appears on this massive rock
formation statues of the three gods of
mortis carved directly into the mountain
we see the father who's pointing out to
the distance to the right the Sun and to
the left that statue was the daughter
but her head has crumbled away there's
actually a curvace formed between her
shoulder and the father some distance
between the two so we have talked before
about the mortise gods they are the
three deities really the Holy Trinity of
Star Wars celestials who come from
another galaxy Ahsoka Anakin and Obi-Wan
meet them in Clone Wars season 3 and
they return in mural artwork outside the
lothal Jedi Temple the daughter gives
Ezra access to the world Between Worlds
and the sun's fist later destroys this
portal the father statue is pointing to
a distant Mountain where we can see a
pillar of light at first I thought this
was a volcano but no the light goes off
on a specific frequency it goes on and
off on and off meaning it's some kind of
artificial Beacon now the full visual
reminds me quite a bit of Mountain Dew
tomb in Lord of the Rings but it might
just be because this father's statue
totally reminds me of the argonath
statues at the gates of Gondor along the
river but when Balin first looked out
from The Fortress Tower in episode 6 he
looked at a mountain range that was
covered in fog and I think that was the
other side of this Cliffside or maybe
the start of the range that leads to
that distant Peak the something stirring
that Balin sensed we now know was
connected to the mortis Gods might have
been the gods themselves their Essence
living on in the realm of mortis and
this tells us that the death Miri the
zepho whoever else was here in paridia
must have known these Gods maybe
worshiped them had some relationship
with them I believe might have gotten
their power from them that they stole
Force sorcery like Prometheus stealing
fire from the gods and that they were
punished for it so I believe what the
father is pointing to what baylin's
destination is is a portal to mortis and
why is Balin so connected to it well
notice if you look closely that blinking
light is the same fiery orange red color
as balance saber and I don't think
that's a coincidence it could be a kind
of mine or heart of kyber that has
crystals this particular color and it's
beckoning all Ronin Wanderers looking
for the pre-jedi order pre-sith order
source of all force abilities now could
that pillar of light be kind of geyser
from the Wellspring of Life Could It Be
bendu farting I I don't know this this
finale asks way more questions than it
provides answers but I do like how this
shot lines up Balin with the father
because the father represented the
balance between the sides of the force
so if balen is the father her who's the
son who's a daughter I think Shin could
be the son someone embracing the dark
side and Ahsoka then would obviously be
the daughter linked with Mori but all
three of these characters are still on
paridia sadly we lost Rey Stevenson too
soon but I would love to see this
explored in animation maybe in the tales
of the Jedi episode we'll see what
happens in the future the eye of Scion
and the Chimera approached deathmere
waiting for them there again are Knights
is to ruins and kujit's tomb and we see
the full bulk of containers and Counting
as many of these piles as we could three
by five by four that would be 60 per
pile some piles are different sizes but
the grand total would be around
5565 containers and again these might
not be corpses they might just be a race
of Knight Brothers and night sisters
that have been in cryogenic stasis that
these witches want to use to repopulate
death Amiri Society Ezra Pilots balance
gold
ETA Class Shuttle that was in the hangar
Bay of the Chimera to the new Republic
Fleet escorted by two a-wings actually
the opening scene of the series was this
ship landing on a new Republic Cruiser
to do some damage but now it is Ezra and
shoppers first to recognize him Ezra and
Hera take each other in it's so
emotional the ghost is behind them we
hear a synthy rendition of the rebels
theme song but no Zeb appearance oh come
on really we end back at the Noti Camp
it's the bean sees Ahsoka looking out at
the illuminated rings of the planets
Sabine though senses something but then
she shrugs it off as nothing
just shadows and a Starlight this might
be a nod to the new Star Wars book Star
Wars the high Republic Shadows of
Starlight that is now available today
and there's actually a little clue in
the music if you listen closely here
what is it
oh my God Kevin keiner includes a subtle
light Motif to Across The Stars Anakin
and padme's love theme from Attack of
the Clones
after Jewel of the Fates it is my
favorite John Williams composition from
the prequels across the Stars what a
perfect song title to end this Ahsoka
series on because no other Star Wars
title has taken us across the Stars
quite like Ahsoka has and Ahsoka gives a
little nod to the force ghost of Anakin
our shadow in the Starlight smiling at
his Snips for making peace with the
student that she feared would make the
same mistakes her master did Ahsoka has
now learned to pass on what you have
learned strength Mastery weakness
Folly failure also yes failure most of
all we are what they grow Beyond
that is the true burden of all Masters
thank you so much for making time out of
your week for us these past two months
there are a lot of great analysis
sources out there that you can find
great Star Wars content from screen
Crush heavy spoilers Star Wars explained
the den of nerds emergency awesome the
folks of the ringer Network and I hope
that we at new rockstars have been able
to bring something to the table to
enrich this experience for you please
subscribe to all three channels of the
new rockstars Network including the
break room where we do our Ahsoka after
shows Wikileaks thanks to Noah Chen for
helping me write and research this
breakdown you can follow me at eavos
follow new rockstars thanks for watching
and
I know
[Music]